etonnant non voici une émission de radio
phonique qui s'appelle les chroniques de
la haine ordinaire parce que c'est un
méchant c'est dur mais c'est ainsi j'ai
beau vivre travailler faire l'amour
sortir jouer avec et non pas sur des
femmes
je continue de passer pour misogyne aux
yeux d'une minorité d'anciennes
combattante ou demeurant plus femelles
que féministe certes mais quand même ça
fait de la peine j'en connais une qui
est fermé aux joies simples de
l'hétérosexualité
au point que quand on lui dit bande elle
pensa velpeau cette femme d'autant plus
déroutante qu'elle ressemble plus à
ornella mutti qu'un chômeur haïtien
voulu tant d'autres temps brûlé brassens
à propos de son hommage à la vénus
callipyge dont voici quelques verres
exquis
madame votre dos perd son nom avec si
bonne grâce qu'on ne peut s'empêcher de
lui donner raison
c'est le duc de bordeaux qui 120 est
basse car il ressemble au mien comme
deux gouttes d'eau s'il ressembler aux
vôtres on dirait quand il passe c'est un
joli garçon que ce duc de bordeaux sans
m'appesantir sur une évidence qui veut
que brassens était aussi anti féministe
que zola était antisémite
et pour en revenir à mon propos avant
que vous ne passiez sur europe 1 pour
écouter elkabbach
imaginez vous que la dame dont je brosse
est ci dessus un portrait succinct
certes mais malhonnête ma
téléphoniquement engueuler pour me
reprocher de n'être pas venue participer
le mois dernier un débat organisé par
l'association des femmes journalistes
sur le thème rabâcher mais toujours
actuel de la cruelle défection féminine
parmi les élus du peuple et dans les
instances dirigeantes des partis et
c'est un fait que les parties sont le
plus souvent entre les mains des hommes
et que les femmes
et que les femmes restent tels à queue
et c'est dommage parce que bon eh bien
ma chère marielle en réalité elle se
prénomme anne-sophie mais je l'appelle
marielle pour faire moins gonzesses en
vérité ma camarade c'est par pure
lâcheté que je n'ai pas honorer
l'aimable invitation de florence
montreynaud
la présidente de la mjc débat organisé
au plm saint jacques à paris ou par
parenthèse les licencie confortable
qu'on petit partout et 3 percheronne
d'un coup sans réveiller l'émirat
pétrole en veilleuse à côté j'ai craint
mes soeurs que vous ne me jugez acier
importuns plutôt qu utile et que vous ne
me lynche acier zoom secoue liasse y est
partout partout sauf au sax et bon temps
la piètre théorie que je vous aurais
soumises m'apparaissait susceptible
d'exacerber votre courroux en effet
j'avais envie de vous suggérer une
hypothèse insoutenable à vous autres qui
souhaitait bâtir un monde en jupon armés
selon laquelle l'une des causes de la
faible participation des femmes sur la
scène politique serait le simple mépris
qu elles en ont s'il ya peu de femmes
boxeurs et boxeuses pardon veegaete
s'il ya peu de femmes boxeur ou colonel
d'infanterie
c'est peut-être parce que la plupart
d'entre elles n'aiment pas prendre des
coups de poing sur la gueule et s'il ya
peu de femmes députées
c'est peut-être parce qu'elles ont mieux
à faire l'après midi que de participer
au désolant d'empoignade entre la rose
fané et le fumier qui la fit éclore
peut-être noms tels qu'indifférence ou
mépris pour tous et en palais bourbon
dont les hippos crétion subalternes
poussent parfois l'honnête homme est
souvent le net femmes à se demander si
l'on ne devrait pas élevé l'absentéisme
électorale au rang de vertu civique et
ne venaient pas poulette me gonfler les
surrénales avec vos accusations de
paternalisme je ne suis pas paternaliste
je puis vous dire au moins trois femmes
très bien de mes amis avec de
l'intelligence et dessins partout
qui sont patronne de leurs affaires et
de leur vie et qu'ils préféreraient
renoncer au port du porte jarretelles
plutôt que d'entrer en politique
allez salut les quilles à la vanille la
prochaine fois c'est juré c'est moi qui
vous invite au plm pour un 5 à 7 non
engagé je connais un jeu formidable
en plus c'est facile c'est pas cher et
moi ça me rapporte rien quant au mois de
mars je le dis sans aucune arrière
pensée politique
ça m'étonnerait qu'ils passent l'hiver
[Applaudissements]
fait non
[Musique]